control
shots fired shots fired
Metro Police releasing the body cam
footage showing the horrifying moments
before officer trueang Tai was shot and
killed last Thursday thank you for
joining us at 11 on Brian Loftus and
tonight we are learning that the suspect
in that shooting was convicted of a
prior weapons charge which begs the
question how did he have two firearms in
the first place let's send it over to
reporter Ryan Matthey near Flamingo and
University Center tonight without police
say the man accused of killing a police
officer obtained a weapon Ryan
well Brian along with how did he get
that gun what was that gun capable of
police say they found two in The
suspect's Possession and the one he used
to kill that metro police officer last
Thursday had potential for much more
he fired with his right hand
back this way towards the officers
assistant Sheriff Andrew Walsh detailing
how a violent gun by a violent man
caused a violent scene last Thursday as
a request of both parties to remained in
custody 18 rounds fired by 24 year old
Tyson Hampton leaving bullets and his
mother-in-law's leg several nearby
vehicles and the Torso of 49 year old
trong Tai who was a metro police officer
for 23 years but officers found two guns
in Hampton's car a Taurus g2s 40 caliber
handgun in the passenger seat the other
which investigators say he used to kill
the officer mimics an AK-47 the Chamber
of an AK with the grip of a pistol
meaning a wider range of motion capable
of firing roughly 600 rounds a minute
but a Metro Police Source telling eight
news now that both guns were legal and
not stolen Clark County court records
show Hampton was convicted of a 2020
misdemeanor where he drew a deadly
weapon in a threatening manner during a
family fight a charge for assault with a
deadly weapon was dismissed in a plea
deal the felony if convicted of it would
have legally prevented Hampton of
possessing a gun though police tell us
that rarely prevents offenders from
possessing how the guns got in his hands
unclear but the shootout's impact
remains we should let officer Ty's death
serve as a stark reminder of what the
men and women who wear this uniform
everyday face
now police say they did retrieve the gun
used in the shooting Hampton he's back
in court tomorrow morning where it's
expected he will be officially charged
with nine crimes reporting live near
Flamingo and University Center Ryan
mathie 8 News Now